[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this place
seems like make-believe or
perhaps the fever dream of a designed
blogger
no one in their right mind would build a
hotel in a forest
and stick the rooms up in some trees
but then again it sort of fits perfectly
because this is sweden and the treehouse
hotel
oozes swede it's nature fornicating with
functional design and creative thinking
this is the ufo and really this
is why we came to sweden to get wi-fi
out here
[Music]
from stockholm to the arctic circle
swedes have pumped out
dazzling tech infused products that put
a new twist
on what it means to be modern
entertaining
and useful on this episode we're gonna
find out how this tiny nation
ended up as perhaps europe's premier
technology power
what's the secret that sweden figured
out that other countries seem to have
missed
because there's no question that these
swedes are up to weird
and wonderful things want proof
we'll check out a face swapping robot
pretty awesome get up close and personal
with the turbine
and that would be kind of equivalent to
uh
and pound cinnamon buns with spotify's
daniel eck
you were going to clubs and and
[Music]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello world
okay here's what you probably know about
stockholm
it's beautiful it's full of gorgeous
unassuming people and it's almost
disturbingly clean what you don't know
about stockholm
is that outside of silicon valley it's
the world leader
in fostering tech addiction spotify
skype and the makers of minecraft and
candy crush
all got their start here the swedes
these supposedly cool passion challenged
people
know how to tap into our desires and
make simple things
we can't escape
[Music]
i started my journey at epicenter a nerd
lounge located
in the heart of stockholm any place
trying to establish its tech cred
needs a spot like this people come here
to fiddle with their robots hash out
their techno-utopian fantasies over beer
and if they're totally nuts insert a
chip
underneath the skin on their wrists that
lets them open
the epicenter door
hello there my name is pho hat about
those robots
[Music]
my reptile brain is telling me that this
thing is alive
and then my intellect tells me no i know
it's just a piece of plastic
and some software we've stumbled upon
something really
super interesting i think this is fur
hat
a promising stab at trying to make
mechanical creatures
and computer interfaces appear and act
more like humans hi my name is ashley
hello ashley nice to meet you i am a
socially intelligent robot
it's nice to meet you as well nice shirt
thank you
we want to build a system that can
interact very fluently with humans
understand their social signals their
emotions their
attention states there's a phenomenon
known
as the uncanny valley it's that queasy
feeling you get
when a robot or computer interface looks
real
but not real enough the brains behind
fur hat
these two hardcore academics think
they're on their way to solving that
problem
and making robots less nauseating we
come from a background of human human
communication understand how humans
interact with each other
is this social layer that is on top of
the typical ai
if they can push the technology forward
fur hat could end up as the face of siri
or amazon's alexa it might keep lonely
people company
do you think i look good or be the thing
you yell at when checking in for a
flight at the airport
can you walk us through like each little
piece
because ferrat is a main piece here
she's got a hat and a wig
and a skull and a mask as far as robots
go
fur hat's design is really simple it's
as easy as taking a mask on
and off and then the mask is
magnetically attached
so you can unplug the mask and then you
can attach a different mask a different
personality
to it and then it needs to be calibrated
so that you can get the right yeah
i do want to see the alien baby what did
you say
[Music]
there is a facial animation system you
know like the ones you do
you have in games and animated movies
yeah so it's all software based and then
we use
a micro projector to project that
animation onto a mask so you get very
accurate
eye movement gestures facial expressions
lip animation
i can look like a woman and sound like a
woman
like an avatar that's that was
freaky but i think the world
has been really waiting for robots at
home to interact with
you know to see them in a human natural
habitat where we don't see any robots at
the moment
one day fur hat might read bedtime
stories to your kid
i'd say it's at the nightmare stage of
that journey
but the product has gone on sale for use
by universities which are busy
tweaking it to ensure sweet dreams in
the years to come
you are boring why would you say that to
me
you look strange or to sling insults
at handsome tv hosts how about beer
sweden's rise as a tech power did not
happen
by accident the country's advanced
industrialization
is due largely to swedish inventions
like the dial telephone
and to high standards in engineering
starting in the late 1990s
the government made a huge investment in
broadband
laying fiber optic cables throughout the
country then it began subsidizing pcs
so every citizen could have a modern
computer with a super fast internet
connection
but this wasn't all about making a
sterile nerd factory
the swedes also designed their education
system to emphasize creativity
and experimentation and to mix the arts
and sciences
one curious offshoot of the social
engineering was that sweden created
a nation of pirates
that generation of tech infused
youngsters set out to pirate
software music movies anything really
and did so with astonishing skill
file sharing services like kazaa and
utorrent
started here and so did an entire
political party
literally called the pirate party one of
the pirates
was this bald beauty daniel eck hey man
hey thank you yes nice to see you
eck ran utorrent and ended up on the
wrong side of the music labels
then he pulled a 180 and decided to try
and become
the music industry's savior by starting
a new
les steely company spotify
it was swedish simplicity that turned
spotify
into a huge hit people could find stream
and download songs with such ease that
neither consumers
nor the labels could resist the service
almost every morning x stops off at
saturnus
a trendy cafe in the ustermom
neighborhood of stockholm
here he engages in fika a swedish
snacking ritual that takes place
a few times a day should we dig in yeah
dig in please
you like him but it was good it's um
seems more wholesome than like a
cinnabon yeah
so you got it set off on the the path of
doing
tech and music so really the only thing
that was important in my family was that
you
learn how to play music i got a guitar
when i was like three four okay
but yeah i got the computer when i was
like five and
uh for me like in the beginning it was
really all about games
um just fun playing from that point i
i kind of realized like hey these games
are boring how hard would it be to try
to
fix the game yeah and so i started
coding games when i was like seven or
eight or something like that it's kind
of amazing that you've been on this
trajectory
yeah you know your whole life yeah i've
never had a normal job
when i grew up like i didn't realize how
you made money
starting something yourself or investing
money or like that was just a totally
foreign concept
outside of silicon valley sweden has the
highest per capita number of unicorns
which are startups valued over one
billion dollars
there's a tension that comes with all
this new money and fame
like much of scandinavia sweden operates
under a cultural code of conduct
known as yantala it's a philosophy that
demands people not think too highly of
themselves
i was wondering if people recognize you
out on the street
um yeah i mean they do but because this
is like sweden
no one really comes up except if it's
like 10 pm and they've had a beer or two
cut to 2016 and this way of living
finds itself in conflict with tech
millionaires boozing it up at clubs
and hyping their tight little apps eck
knows the situation
as well as you anyone by the time you're
21 i mean you were a millionaire
essentially right because you had sold a
couple businesses and done very well for
yourself
and then it sounds like you went through
sort of a period
where i don't know if showing off is the
right word but you were living
oh yeah going to clubs and driving fast
cars
when i look back to it i'm sort of
almost ashamed of myself because it was
like
you know it was
today i realized there was a huge sort
of period of insecurity
um it was a lot of fun don't get me
wrong
um but it's it's like not who i
am and i never know like as an outsider
if we make too much of all this but this
idea that um you don't want to stand out
in sweden or scandinavia
and you do stand out when you when you
start making billions of dollars it's
kind of hard to
uh yeah but it is changing i mean if you
walk around in the city now like i see
like ferraris lamborghinis like there's
quite a lot of that here which
is not really part of the fabric of how
it used to be
to really contemplate yantala i took
part
in another swedish tradition known as
standing pensively against a wall
completely aware that i was being
photographed for my own tv show
[Music]
here are some of the rules of yantala
you are not to think you are anything
special you are not to think you're as
good as we are you're not to think
you're smarter than we are you're not to
convince yourself that you're better
than we are you're not to think you know
more than we do not to think you're more
important than you're not to think
you're good at anything not to laugh at
us you're not to think anyone cares
about you
you're not to think you can teach us
anything
ah that was refreshing
with the brainwashing portion of the
program over
it was time to live a little we decided
to get out of the cold
dine at a traditional swedish restaurant
and then hit the town philippe just
might be getting you guys lost
i'm ashley nice to meet you thank you
henrik all right nice to meet you man
america oh promised country
i'll tell you this about yantala it
gives way
after a few cocktails you have to mix
this with the
lemon and the oats margarine i don't
know what it's called in sweden they
call it snacks
that's why everybody gets wrong because
they just
and that's when the other part of the
swedish character the friendly
joyful lubricated part goes on full
display
hey hope
near the end of foreign night it was
time for my famous disappearing
cigarette magic trick
[Music]
i guess it and my man bun need some work
as vibrant as the startup scene is in
stockholm sweden's technology muscle
lies in the northern part of the country
head 560 miles up from stockholm and
you'll end up in lulio
a picturesque city of 70 000 people
wedged between the gulf of bothnia and
the arctic circle
for centuries lulio has been a cultural
and economic hub of this region
but what really has lulio buzzing these
days is the arrival of facebook
which opened a data center on the
outskirts of the city in 2013.
at 300 000 square feet it's one of the
largest computer centers
ever built it's the kind of place you
need a bike
and a picnic lunch to explore fully and
while you're on that picnic lunch
you can take a selfie and post it here
yo it's nice to see you again hi ashley
welcome to lilio thank you
and welcome to facebook joel shellgren
has managed the operations
at the lulio data plant since it opened
he offered to show us the guts
of this beastly building
some people think the cloud is actually
a cloud
for others it's an ethereal mystery the
place where your photos and documents
get sucked to
and hang out this though
is the cloud at least the physical
manifestation of it
it's thousands of servers and storage
systems working together
to hold our information this is where
all the action happens this is where all
our
photos are like this is really
where facebook is actually running
look around see over there it's a
picture of a young ashley vance
who thought that going blonde would be a
good idea
and that one it's a lingering poke from
your creepy ex
and right there is an inspirational meme
helping lift people's spirits
where does my mom find all these amazing
quotes
and because we've built the
infrastructure to be so redundant
we can basically pull any server and
it's not going to affect
any end user in any negative way so we
pull one out here
okay so we're going to take down
facebook
[Laughter]
but it's all built to be as energy and
cooling efficient as possible so there
are no fans at all on this one as you
can see they're sort of
it's just working on the pressure
difference that forces the air through i
think for most people who've never been
to a data center they're usually like
these big sort of pizza box
shaped things with tons of fans and
moving parts going on them and you guys
compacted everything down if the
industry in general started adopting a
lot more of this thinking it could
really change the whole industry and not
just facebook
a couple of corridors will go through a
typical data center relies on massive
air conditioning units
to pump cool air onto tens of thousands
of computers
you can't pay for this kind of wind
blowing look facebook
is too hip for that
[Music]
ketchup it uses cool arctic air to keep
its photo friend and like machines from
melting down
this whole place lends itself to
sweden's meticulous attention
to detail and design the building is an
engineering marvel
that treats air like a pampered corgi
poo the air gets sucked in
cleaned watered and then set on its way
via physics with the building pressure
pushing the air down onto the computers
since facebook gives away its service
for free this place needs to operate as
smoothly
and cheaply as possible to minimize the
cost
of each click off camera you'll readily
brags about facebook's cheap clicks
on camera yantala so we've kind of been
dodging around the point i mean this may
be the world's most efficient power
efficient
data center it's most likely one of the
most efficient ones
damn swedish modesty
[Music]
it's not just free cold air that brought
facebook to the arctic circle
the social network also came for the
cheap reliable power
produced by sweden's vast set of
hydroelectric dams
starting in 1910 the swedes began
building
a network of two dozen hydroelectric
dams along the lule river
today the dams provide more than enough
power
to meet all of northern sweden's needs
so now we will start the journey
lulay river on lula river power rick
abramson
and christopher lundgren work for
vaughtenfall the energy giant that runs
the dams
they were kind enough to take me on a
road trip to see up close
how these amazing machines work
these guys insist that it's wonderful
living in the great
frigid north they can check out the
northern lights from their hot tubs
spend months in total darkness and hunt
bears
and moose so rick did you already go
moose hunting this year then
the small hunting ground where i'm part
of there's only one
grown-up and one calf and the first
morning 30 minutes into the hunt
they shot the big one then hunting is
over
and everyone's done walk me through
again like how many
dams there are along we'll do that we
have
15 power stations along this river
of course with great power comes great
responsibility
and you know stuff to placate people
that care about nature
and fish we're one of the largest uh
fish breeders in sweden
to compensate for the fact that we built
all the power stations because the
salmon cannot sort of pass through the
river system now so the energy company
breeds salmon yeah
we do how many would you have to put
back in per year uh
in the lulu river we put back close to
half a million every year
wow it used to take hundreds of people
to run these dams
but today they're controlled by two
easy-going swedes
working in this command center from here
we control the complete river system
15 power stations and we have two guys
here who controls the
complete river that's what seems
incredible to me is that two people
would handle
uh half a country's power yeah yeah
you could essentially turn on a turbine
and shut off a turbine and
so today that's all done through
software yeah on the rest of our journey
today we'll get to go and see some of
these
absolutely you're going to see the
biggest one we have in sweden and that
would be kind of equivalent
to uh block okay yeah an ordinance
van fall has turbines of all sizes
some of them like this big beauty named
ester
you see the size of it yeah it's huge
produce as much power
as a nuclear reactor down we go
this is what you've been waiting for
this feels like the seconds before a
shuttle loan yeah it does feel like that
i've been to a couple yeah
how long does it take to get up to full
speed
here comes the water
standing next to one of these turbines
when it fires up is one of life's great
organ rattling pleasures it's
unbelievable
how fast it goes the closer you get the
more manly you feel
for some totally insane reason 250 cubic
meters a second
long in there water going through yeah
incredible that's absolutely amazing
after getting my organs rattled i
decided to head back to lulio
and decompress damn what a day
it's been a long but awesome week in
sweden
somehow we ended up near the arctic
circle
with a campfire it's our lucky day
i've been to sweden a few times and this
trip confirmed
my previous impressions about the
country
these are pleasant people who are
remarkably good at making things
everyone wants but what's more
impressive these days
is the way in which the swedes are
embracing technology
the people here try harder than anyone
else
to find a balance between striving for a
bright future
while living within their means and then
you know cinnamon buns
on the next episode of hello world we go
to israel
where i float in the dead sea is there a
technique to us
hop in a jet and build a space
laboratory
it seems hard to believe that you could
do that much science in something
this size